[Musique]
je suis né
légèrement avant l'indépendance
donc j'ai été nourri
à la sève de la porte musique
parce que
à cette période là
la Côte d'Ivoire était la plaque
tournante de la pop musique en Afrique
de l'Ouest
et tout l'environnement
était la porte
j'écoutais des grands artistes
comme les Bob villages
les 10
les Peter Gabriel
tous ces gens
cités
mais cette musique qui m'avait vu naître
et dans laquelle j'avais grandi qui me
plaisait m'avait toujours laissé un goût
d'une
je ne savais pas pourquoi
et un jour
j'ai entendu chanter un grand cousin
du nom de Martial Trevi
dans notre langue maternelle une chanson
sur des accords de pop musique
et je me suis dit tiens
voilà la pop que j'attendais
parce que ce jour
j'avais compris
ce qui me manquait dans cette musique
qui me laissait toujours en couple
et ce jour je l'avais entendu ça fait
vraiment un déclic dans ma tête
et
après la mort de mes parents
puisque mes parents sont morts trop tôt
je venais d'avoir mon certificat d'étude
primaire et mon entrée en 6e
nous pouvons plus continuer
je me suis dit
que réaliser cette pop à la connotation
africaine que j'appelle aujourd'hui des
époques qui est la traduction musicale
de l'expression corporelle dans la vie
de tous les jours selon les événements
allez être au centre de ma vie
et je suis allé
voir mon grand frère qui était en
fonction dans le nord de la Côte
d'Ivoire
je suis resté une année avec lui
et quand je m'en suis rendu compte que
c'était pas l'endroit idéal
je suis venu à Abidjan
précisément
[Musique]
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer un
cousin qui était le guitariste des Black
Pearl de Treichville et c'est lui qui
m'a intégré au groupe comme batteur
mais les blancs c'était pas un groupe de
professionnels c'était des gens de
quartier la plupart des élèves
donc il n'avait pas les moyens de
s'offrir du matériel adapté
donc moi je faisais de la batterie sur
la caisse des résonance de guitariste
on a évolué comme ça jusqu'en 1974
et il a eu le festival pop des artistes
en herbe de Côte d'Ivoire
et c'est pendant les préparatifs de ce
festival que j'ai pris le microphone
j'ai proposé
des chansons de ma composition
au groupe
puisque c'est un chantier dans ma langue
à cette époque personne ne pensait à ça
c'était tellement original que le groupe
a accepté et nous sommes partis à ce
festival moi comme l'aide vocale
de la peur
notre prestation a été un véritable
succès
dès mon apparition sur la scène
il y a eu un mouvement de foule
il a eu un moment de folie
puisque la joie était tellement intense
ça courait de partout
et ce jour quand j'ai fini ma prestation
je suis rentré au quartier je suis
rentré comme un héros
tout le quartier
toute la jeunesse de mon quartier
comme un président de la République
et les jours qui ont suivi
du pont de Marcory
jusqu'à la cité policière de Treichville
tous les jeunes connaissaient mon nom
et c'est ce festival qui m'a ouvert
la porte du professionnel
j'ai joué avec les selles de 2000 de
France à Louvain
j'ai joué avec les Billy Andres Alex de
do Albert
j'ai joué avec le fl2000
l'orchestre DJ
mais cette fois c'était des
professionnels au niveau professionnel
c'était plus pour que je chante des
chansons de ma composition les choses
avaient changé
et moi qui n'a aucune formation de
musique qui venait de mon village
je ne savais pas quoi faire
mais grâce à l'aide
des musiciens plus à guéris au monde
qui m'ont donné des méthodes
comme wonky le papa du célèbre d'hier à
Arafat et son âme
c'est lui qui m'a dit
comment je dois faire pour tenir la note
sur les accords qui passent pour ne pas
que je sorte de temps
tu es une méthode que j'ai travaillé il
a eu blanche et noire qui était notre
batteur lui il m'enseigner comment les
boucles de musique se succédaient les
unes derrière les autres pour te
permettre d'étaler ton champ et toujours
retomber sur tes pieds
et il y a eu des gens lui il m'a montré
comment je pouvais transcrire des
chansons et les interpréter facilement
parce que c'était des chansons chanter
dans des langues que je comprenais pas
comme l'anglais
comme l'espagnol comme le Portoricain
comme le créole comme le lingala mais il
fallait le faire parce que on te demande
de le faire dans toute cette technique
là m'ont permis
d'abattre les différentes tâches qu'on
me confier parce que je me suis
approprié
et
c'est groupe avec lesquels je
travaillais
c'était déjà vraiment des gens avancés
donc il pensait vraiment à moi et cela a
duré jusqu'en 1980
c'est beaucoup appris
sur la route parce que moi je suis pas
allé à l'école de musique je n'ai aucune
formation musicale
mais j'ai trouvé des compagnons sur la
route du mot montrer les techniques et
avec ça j'ai évolué
et en 1980
j'étais vraiment bien routier je
comprenais mieux le métier je me suis
dit maintenant je peux me prendre en
charge
et j'ai arrêté avec un maître Gims
et j'ai cherché des voisins
pour entrer en Europe
et j'ai rencontré en 1982
en couple dans le mari
travaillait à l'Afrique
c'est ce frère
qui m'a donné un billet d'avion pour que
j'ai en Europe
me frotter au musicien plus aguerri dans
la pratique de la porte parce que ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de réaliser
cette pop musique à la connotation
africaine
c'était ça mon projet
je suis arrivé à Paris complètement
j'avais 35 francs CFA
dans ma poche
sans adresse
et sans habit de rechange et je suis
arrivé à 7h du matin
à Roissy Charles de Gaulle
j'étais vraiment déconnecté désolé
dans la dans l'aéroport jusqu'à 16
et après je suis sorti sur l'esplanade
de la yoroga je viens un bus
j'ai couru vers le bus
j'ai emprunté le bus
le bus m'a laissé en plein centre de
Paris Gare de l'Est
moi qui ne connaissait pas Paris qui n'a
rien
j'ai suivi mon instinct
j'ai marché
sans savoir où je vais je marchais
jusqu'à 22h
depuis 7h que je suis arrivé
sans manger jusqu'à 22h
et je me suis rendu compte que j'étais
une place qu'on appelait place
Saint-Michel
c'est sur cette place que j'avais un
banc sur le trottoir
je me suis affalé sur le banc
et j'ai dormi la 2 jours sans manger
j'étais dans un état
et le troisième jour
je me suis levé cette assis sur mon banc
et je dis un autre SDF comme moi qui est
assis dans le coin et il avait une
guitare
c'est lui qui m'a prêté sa guitare et
moi
j'ai commencé à chanter cette chanson
que j'avais écrite
en mémoire
de ma
défunte mère qui m'avait
quitté trop tôt
qui est l'amour d'un enfant
qui regrette que sa mère ne soit pas là
pour qu'il lui couvre le cadeau
est en train de pratiquer cette chanson
et une voiture s'est arrêtée à ma
hauteur
la vie c'est ABC
j'ai vu une dame blanche
dans certains nages qui me regardaient
et quand j'ai su que me regarder
je me suis appliqué
[Applaudissements]
je me suis appliqué et j'ai donné de la
voix parce que j'avais déjà du métier
donc tu as assuré ça correctement
et c'est cette chanson
que cette femme blanche a écouté et elle
est venue me sortir des griffes de
l'enfer qui voulaient me broyer
[Applaudissements]
elle m'a donné un toit
et c'est encore ses dents qui m'a dit
tu vas aller à Strasbourg Saint-Denis je
suis sûr
que tu trouveras
la question comment dire la réponse à
tes questions je ne savais pas pourquoi
elle a dit ça mais je suis allé à faire
Goussainville
j'ai vu tous les frères africains
ça sortait de partout
j'ai regardé et j'ai reconnu
hein que je connaissait depuis très cher
est-ce que tu nous connaîtrais pas mon
petit frère Allah qui est-il 2 ans avant
moi et d'ici ouais
son numéro
j'ai pris le numéro j'ai appelé mon
petit frère je suis allé chez lui quand
j'ai vu qu'il était bien je l'ai dit
petit et si je veux rester
naturellement il a accepté
et maintenant que j'avais retrouvé ma
famille
j'ai commencé
à chercher des compagnons de chemin pour
réaliser mon projet parce que ce qui me
tient à coeur c'est ça c'est la
réalisation de cette pop musique à
connotation africaine
j'ai rencontré un grand guitariste le
guitariste de Bernard Lavilliers je sais
pas si vous le connaissez c'est un grand
chanteur français il avait écrit une
musique
[Musique]
et il voulait un artiste pour mettre une
voix dessus c'est ce que j'ai fait et
notre collaboration c'est soldé
par l'enregistrement d'un 45 tours chez
phonographe qui malheureusement n'a pas
été commercialisé en Côte d'Ivoire faute
et je regardais j'ai dit vraiment c'est
bien tout ça mais c'est pas la musique
que je voulais moi je veux ma porte à
moi
et lui son registre d'un peu la world
musique tout ça tu dis non donc je
continue à chercher et je suis tombé sur
deux jeunes dans le quartier des
excellents musiciens mais des jeunes de
quartier Jean-François Kerner ils
allaient
j'ai soumis mon projet et ils ont adhéré
et puis nous nous sommes mis au travail
mais les sciences de répétition je me
croyais déjà sur des gros stades en
train de faire des concerts
tellement je rendais le champ
les enfants ils sont hépatés ils me
voient un Africain qui sort de la forêt
qui chantent de la pop à ce niveau
jusqu'en un jour à une répétition bien
enlevée
ce jour-là
j'ai précisé la chanson
parce que j'en avais grossi le coeur le
guitariste s'est arrêté il m'a demandé
mais John toi tu viens d'Afrique
et tu chantes la porte
comment tu fais et je l'ai dit que moi
j'ai été nourri à la sève la pop musique
depuis mon village
c'est ma musique et moi je suis venu ici
pour mettre mon roi sur dessus
il a été tellement heureux
donc on a repris mais c'était des
journées intenses de pratique de musique
non stop
jusqu'à ce que on est un répertoire
fourni parce que j'avais accumulé
beaucoup de chansons dans ma tête dans
chaque fois qu'on répétait je précisais
le champ
et les instrumentistes étaient prêts
pour faire ça et
on a eu beaucoup de chansons jusqu'à
1984 on enregistré notre premier album
qui était
en 84 et en 85
il y a eu le président son Excellence
Félix houët-boigny qui a eu besoin des
artistes pour le concert de la paix en
Côte d'Ivoire
et on m'a dit de venir aussi je suis
j'ai eu deux prestations
ma prestation Abidjan a été interrompu
par la pluie j'ai commencé il a plu
je dis
après ils nous ont convoyé sur Bouaké
c'était la catastrophe
j'ai chanté devant un stade le stade est
resté comme ça mais
comme si tout ce que je faisais ne les
intéressait pas
c'est quoi cette société
qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont écrit sur moi je
peux pas vous le dire
j'ai hésité abattu même
mais je me suis dit comme si quelqu'un
qui se décourage pas comme ça parce que
j'avais foi
à ma porte musique à connotation
africaine donc je dis c'est pas grave
moi je retournerai en France j'irai
travailler et je reviendrai relever le
défi
et je l'ai fait je suis parti j'ai mis 5
et je suis revenu en 1990 en ce moment
j'avais changé de nom
j'étais désormais John y aller
parce qu'au départ c'était John Maya et
là j'avais changé passé tellement la vie
était dur sur moi que je me suis dit que
non c'est moi il y a les mêmes voilà
c'est l'origine du nom
et je suis venu en Côte d'Ivoire avec ça
et quand j'ai mis l'album sur le marché
ça a été un succès fou
cet album a été vendu plus d'un million
d'exemplaires
c'était du jamais vu en Côte d'Ivoire
et j'ai fait suivre
ces époques expériences
là
ça m'a consolidé
et j'ai commencé à faire des séries de
concerts
comme le parc de Treichville
un concert où les gens regardaient ma
musique avec mes petits blancs venus
d'Europe en train de pratiquer les gens
ils regardent il y a d'autres me dire
non ça là c'est pas vrai
il est en train de nous mentir
c'est plus bas qui fait là c'est pas
musique papa
beaucoup de croyaient pas qu'on avait
joué en live parce que les artistes qui
sont venus avec moi ce sont des gens qui
sont rompus
à la pratique musicale
et ils avaient trouvé un chanteur
africain qui voulait pas se laisser
faire
ah oui parce qu'ils sont venus chez moi
et c'est mon business donc je suis
devant donc je dors
c'est pas pour rigoler mais ma nature
est comme ça
quand je suis devant une scène je viens
pour les assujettis c'est ça qui est
dans ma tête je ne viens pas
pour venir m'amuser
donc on a fait un concert fou au parc de
Treichville les gens ne croient pas et
on a remis au stade de l'université ce
jour-là je sais que dans la salle il y a
des gens qui ont vu ce spectacle
ce jour-là c'était la folie
il y a le le grand portail d'entrée du
stade est tombé ce jour-là il a eu des
blessés malheureusement il y a même une
fille
elle avait un gros bras droit sur la
tête elle est venue je suis venu pour
que tu voies ce que ta musique a fait
sur moi
c'était la folie
j'ai regardé
et à Gagnoa voilà on est arrivé à Gagnoa
que ma ville natale c'est cela le
concert a commencé
après une pluie
donc les musiciens moi dès qu'on est
monté en volume et qu'on a les décibels
ont commencé à prendre l'espace on a vu
des gens se dénuder
des garçons comme des filles dans un
stade tu recrues à une fête d'initiation
et il y avait deux dosons qui faisaient
la sécurité devant la scène
l'autre il regarde son ami il me regarde
il voit l'ambiance et il demande à son
ami il lui demande est-ce que moi le
chanteur là est-ce que c'est un être
humain
je voyais tout ça je rigolais
après ça on est parti et on a envoyé
je te disais
alors je te disent des concerts
tout le peuple a adhéré j'avais plus
rien à dire
jusqu'à ce qu'on envoie
Destiny en
c'était cuit les fans j'en comptais pas
millier dans les rues les gens me voient
John tu n'es pas l'homme
les aider mais si je suis pas un homme
je suis comme vous
d'autres
et en 2000 j'ai enlevé le pied sur
l'accélérateur et j'ai regardé dans le
rétroviseur
Jésus les dégâts
et je me suis dit oui
j'avais réussi
à imposer mon truc les époques
cette pop musique à connotation
africaine je l'avais réussi tout le
peuple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais dire
à ces gens qui me disaient à l'époque
mais quand il faut que tu te fasses que
tu chantes pas en français que ta
musique
n'a pas d'ouverture que là n'était pas
mon objectif
mon objectif était de revaloriser le
patrimoine que m'avait laissé les
ancêtres
c'est ce que j'ai toujours fait et c'est
ce que je continue de faire
aux jeunes africains je veux leur dire
n'est pas honte de parler volant
n'ayez pas apprenez vos langues à vos
descendants
nos langues sont
le patrimoine que nous ont laissé nos
ancêtres et notre rôle est de le faire
valoir non de les terres au détriment de
doute langues c'est ce que j'avais
toujours fait
et c'est pour cela que je suis là
aujourd'hui devant vous et vous me
regardez
il faut travailler en les choses
quand il y a une situation
il faut regarder il faut bien
l'empréhender
et travailler rien que travailler c'est
ça qui fait que tu arrives au bout de
tes objectifs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]